DENISE WINKLER: Hello.
Welcome, everyone.
My name is Denise Winkler.
I'm a strategic business
executive with Google Cloud.
And I'm pleased to introduce
our guest and client Jennifer
Ricker, assistant secretary
for the Illinois Department
of Innovation and Technology.
In today's session, we're going
to outline the programs that
make up the social safety net,
the impact that COVID-19 has
had on citizens and the social
safety net system, the Google
solutions that
have been mobilized
to assist these agencies.
And Jennifer's going to share
with us how Google Contact
Center AI supported the Illinois
Department of Employment
Security.
Then we'll close
with a discussion
on how Google Analytics can
help our communities to reopen
and recover.
More than 54 million citizens
applied for unemployment
in the last 20 weeks.
As we implemented stay at home
orders and social distancing,
citizens were directed to
portals and call centers
to apply for safety
net services.
This unprecedented volume of
citizens in need of services
has overwhelmed agency websites,
call centers, and staff.
Social safety net programs
provide critical services,
unemployment, food, cash,
and housing assistance,
health care, child support,
and protective services
for abused children
and the elderly.
Leading economists are
projecting that more than 40%
of the jobs will not come back.
So caseload sizes in these
social safety net programs
are going to remain
at record highs.
And in addition to that,
state and local governments
are facing record
revenue shortfalls.
Reduced tax revenue,
high unemployment,
and just the cost of
responding to the pandemic
may force many states to
make painful spending cuts.
So, essentially, local
and state governments
will need to serve this
unprecedented number
of citizens with less resources.
We've all been
impacted by COVID-19.
But as we look across the social
safety net and the stakeholders
involved in this process,
citizens have lost their jobs
or become ill.
They need these
benefits quickly.
And the portals and call
centers are overwhelmed.
And many of these
individuals and families
have never applied
for services before.
So they need basic
guidance on how to apply
or even what benefits
they're eligible for.
And they're also facing the
uncertainty of relief programs.
What will be available?
What won't be available?
Employees of these agencies are
also overwhelmed by the volume.
They've had to
almost immediately
change and implement new
programs and new business
processes.
Many of them are working from
home for the first time ever.
They may lack the appropriate
equipment or training
to do that well.
And like us, many of them have
children and families at home.
The agencies themselves,
they're struggling
with their current
legacy systems.
These systems were never built
to manage this kind of volume.
And they also can't
quickly be enhanced
to support new programs
like Pandemic Unemployment
Assistance.
So as a result, many
of these agencies
and their administrators
are facing
significant public and
political pressure.
And in addition to that,
they've had to, again,
almost overnight
develop new processes,
enable their staff
to work remotely.
And that's a huge culture change
from what is predominantly
been an in-office culture.
And then, finally,
these agencies
have a responsibility
to make sure
that the benefits are being
distributed to citizens
who are eligible and to prevent
improper payments and fraud.
As we've worked with
local and state agencies
across the country, we
notice that they're actually
facing four primary problems,
volume, new programs
and legislation, how do
they engage virtually,
then reopening and recovery.
And Google has mobilized
a series of solutions
to address these issues.
Volume, for example, we've
implemented virtual waiting
rooms that control traffic
to public-facing portals.
But more importantly, they
provide better service,
and they help calm citizens.
They calm them,
one, by providing
a clock using AI
and machine learning
to tell them how long they
have to wait to apply.
They also provide information
by bringing forward FAQs
so they can spend
their time effectively
while they're waiting.
We've implemented very
sophisticated virtual agents
on both portals
and call centers.
And these are not your first
generation automated FAQs
or tinny mechanical voices.
Using artificial intelligence
and a highly developed
natural language
conversational engines,
these virtual agents
can answer questions
and complete routine tasks with
really human-like engagement.
And Jennifer's going to
talk about her experiences
with our intelligent
agents coming up next.
We've also used AI
and machine learning.
We've automated a great deal
of processing of documents.
Government programs,
especially safety net programs,
begin and end with documents.
And many of these agencies given
the increase in applications
are drowning in paper documents
and all sorts of documents.
So Google can create
and train a model
that can digitize and
ingest a document,
extract that data
off the document,
whether the document is
handwritten or typed.
It can pull the data off
and put it into fields.
It can index the
documents to a case, then
validate and match
that document.
So for example, if a citizen
has submitted an application
and a verification document like
a driver's license or a utility
bill, it can match
and verify that.
And then it can
automatically input that data
into your core case
management system.
This enables agencies to
redeploy those human agents
to higher value activities and
help citizens work through much
more difficult problems.
With new legislation, we've
been able to rapidly develop
applications and
alternative data collection
for new programs like
the Pandemic Unemployment
Assistance or improper payments.
And then more importantly, we
can integrate that module back
into the legacy system.
So this enables agencies
to quickly administer
these new programs, control
volume to their website
and data to their portals.
With virtual engagement,
our virtual collaboration
and conferencing solution
G Suite's Google Meet
enables agencies to not only
support a remote workforce
but enable virtual service
delivery to citizens.
Whether it's meetings
and collaboration
between coworkers, between
government staff and community
providers, or providing
virtual services to citizens,
Google Meet is
ideal for government
to citizen interaction
because it only
requires a web-enabled device.
And when we come to
reopen and recovery,
states are going to need to
look for efficiencies to manage
the continued high volume.
The solutions we've
already talked
about, such as intelligent
agents, automatic document
processing, rapid
AI, those can be
expanded across the government
ecosystem to other programs
to help gain those efficiencies.
In addition, other solutions
are going to be needed.
Getting people back to
work will be critical.
So virtual career
centers that can help
support a much higher
volume of citizens
who are seeking reentry
into the job market.
Given the number of citizens
and the dollars associated
with these programs,
agencies will
need solutions that identify
improper payments and fraud.
And then finally, and
probably most importantly,
data analytics will be critical.
And we're going to cover
some data analytics options
at the end of our session.
But it's always nice to hear
about outcomes from clients.
So Jennifer would you
share some of the issues
that the Illinois Department of
Employment Security was facing
and how Google Contact Center
AI was able to help your agency.
JENNIFER RICKER: Sure.
Thank you, Denise.
And thank you again for letting
me have the opportunity here
to share the challenges
that Illinois specifically
was facing and, in particular,
the Illinois Department
of Employment Security.
So like what you just
described, the situation
that was happening
across the country
was the same really
for Illinois.
Shortly after the
pandemic began,
we began to see a large,
really unprecedented volume
of inquiries and
activities on our website,
calls to our contact
center, and attempts
to file new
unemployment requests.
And these changes were really--
the amount, the volumes
that we were seeing
have never been experienced
before in the state.
So to say we weren't
necessarily prepared for that
was an understatement.
So we're talking about really
orders of magnitude difference.
An average day prior to the
pandemic for our website,
for IDES's website would
have been maybe 40,000 hits
in a day versus what
we started to see,
a million hits in a day, which
quickly impacted our servers
and the system itself
that was trying
to process the applications.
So on the other
end of that, then,
when our residents were
unable to get to the website,
get their questions
answered there,
then they start calling
the contact center, which
then overwhelms the
agents on the phones
and overwhelms that
system as well.
So it really became
just a snowball effect
for all channels.
And I'll mention, too, that
one of the reasons this also
snowballed-- previously,
the Department of Employment
Security like a lot
of our state agencies
was still dealing with a lot
of very manual, very paper
processes, a lot of walk-ins
at their local offices,
which, obviously, with the
shut down, those had to close.
That contact and that avenue
of connecting with the state
was closed to our residents.
So, again, that helped
to drive the volumes
that we were seeing on the
website and on the phones.
So really as we
started to look at what
are the solutions for this,
thinking about the volumes
that we were receiving,
there was absolutely
no way we were going to, one,
hire enough agents quick enough
and train them quick enough
to handle this kind of volume.
So frankly, this type of
technology becoming that force
multiplier was the only
solution, the quickest
solution, and the best solution.
So the way we handled
that was really
to begin to work with
Google and really implement
this virtual agent
contact center technology.
And it was, I will
say, much easier
than I would have
expected, quicker
than I would have expected.
And we were very
successful with that.
So the first phase
was really deploying
that and what we thought
could be the quickest
and what would have the
biggest impact first.
And that was really
on our website
and deploying the
chatbot onto the website.
Again, that was
highly successful.
I will say within the first
two weeks of operation,
I think it handled three
million or more web inquiries.
We were also able to
verify as you talked
about Google's Analytics
and the ability
to track really what's
happening behind the scenes.
We were able to pull
the data from there
and take a look at
dashboards to know
that not only did it handle
that number of inquiries,
but those were almost
without fail successful.
So the questions
that were being asked
were being answered
successfully.
And we also were able to
very easily add new intents
and change those
intents, as you mentioned
the legislation
that changed quite
frequently on the federal side.
So as those changes
happened, it was much easier
to add those changes, intents
and add new intents to the bot
so that residents as they
have new questions about,
OK, this just changed, or
how do I apply for this,
or do I qualify for
this, it's really easy
rather than trying to
search through the website,
they can just easily ask the
question in, as you mentioned,
a very conversational
manner with the web bot.
And then same thing.
After we got that up and
running and successful,
we moved on to our contact
center, again, very easy,
although we did integrate
with our technology
that we utilized to
run our contact center.
Again, it was relatively easy.
We've been able
to utilize, again,
the same type of intense.
It's very conversational.
People are able to
speak to the agent.
So that has been really
surprisingly very, very much
beneficial to us as well.
And I would also mention
that previously IDES,
their contact center was
a during the day type
of operation.
So adding this virtual
agent to the phone
allowed those
questions to continue
to be answered after
hours, all night long,
over the weekends,
et cetera, so, again,
the ability for us to really
quickly implement these.
They're easy to scale.
They're easy to continue
to manage and maintain.
Has been phenomenal for us.
And we continue to expand
this to other agencies
as well, other
agencies' websites.
So we're really pleased
with how this has really
rolled out and been deployed.
So thank you again
for letting me share.
And I'll turn it
back to you, Denise.
DENISE WINKLER:
Thank you, Jennifer.
In the midst of one of the
largest surges of citizens
who need services,
your story really
demonstrates the unique
capability and value
of Google Cloud technology.
It can scale to
petabytes of data,
enabling states to manage
that extraordinary volume.
The time to deliver, we were
able to deliver these solutions
in days and weeks, not months.
It's also serverless, so there's
no hardware installation.
And I think integration
is also important.
We were able to modernize
critical components
and then integrate them
with an existing legacy
system, which provides
the cost effectiveness.
Our approach to public sector
is to be cost effective
but also to make that
cost predictable.
And so these are the principles
that support governments
in modernizing around some
of these legacy systems
in dealing with
this current issue.
So let's spend a
little time talking
about how we can support
recovery with analytics.
Everyone, citizens and leaders,
want to reopen and recover.
But one of the key components
of success is data.
As a 20-year veteran
of social services,
I realized that the
social safety net
agencies could be overwhelmed.
But providing the data to
state and local leaders
to address that challenge
would be difficult.
So I engaged with
Google Cloud Value
Advisors, our center
of excellence,
to work with federal and state
publicly available data sets so
that we could provide
dashboards that would help
estimate the potential economic
impact of relief programs
and the potential increase
for citizen applications
and involvement in
safety net programs.
And this type of data
would help state leaders
be able to develop data-driven
plans to support citizens
in our communities.
So, initially, we thought
that leaders needed insights
into four key areas.
It would help to understand
the vulnerable industry sectors
in their state or community.
Since economists have
estimated that 40% of the jobs
won't recover, how much of
your state's employment basis
is at risk?
Second, given the high
level of unemployment,
what percentage of
your state's economy
is coming from temporary
relief programs
and from traditional
safety net programs?
Thirdly, what is the impact
to your state's economy
when relief programs
are added or expired?
And then, also, what is the gap
when temporary relief programs
are gone?
So this particular dashboard,
Employment Vulnerability--
our Cloud Value
Advisors developed
a series of dashboards to
visualize these insights.
This particular dashboard
shows the percentage
of vulnerable industry sectors
nationally and also by state.
So for example,
leisure and hospitality
are vulnerable as
well as retail.
This dashboard estimates that
39.1% of the US employment
is in vulnerable industries.
This type of data can
also be shown by states.
So it would enable
state and local leaders
to develop much more
effective recovery plans
for their particular community.
The Contribution of Benefits.
There are a multitude
of state, federal,
and local relief programs
that are providing benefits
to citizens.
But at the same
time, those benefits
are contributing to that
community's economy.
So using the Federal Pandemic
Unemployment Compensation
as an example, this
dashboard estimates how much
Federal Pandemic
Unemployment Compensation
contributes to a state's
gross domestic product.
So it provides
leaders with insights
into the economic impact
of those programs.
So, again, leaders can develop
the policies to address
those specific issues.
And then Economic
Impact and Surge.
As different relief
programs expire,
citizens may be eligible
for other programs.
This dashboard estimates the
potential surge, for example,
in food assistance applications
as the Pandemic Unemployment
Compensation expires.
This will enable leaders
to be better prepared
for the impact of these surges.
At Google, we spent a great
deal of time discussing
how technology can
assist social safety net
agencies, and our
communities, and country
in reopening and recovery.
But in closing, I think
it's important to keep
in mind that when systems
that support social safety net
programs slow or fail, there's
a very real human cost.
Children go hungry.
Rent can't be paid.
Lives are impacted.
Keeping these
systems functioning
is critical to our citizens, our
communities, and our recovery.
And Google is committed to
assisting wherever it can.
Thank you for your time today.